for Annie It's like very Bittersweet to
talk to you because like I love you so
much and I loved you on the show but
like everything that happened last night
I'm so so sad about it I was rooting for
you to make it far
but now that it's out there it's been
months and now everyone has seen it how
are you feeling
oh I'm feeling so good I mean genuinely
like every moment of this whole thing
was so joyful for me like I didn't even
feel sad watching it back because I just
had so much fun and like what if if
you're gonna go go on an episode where
everyone's like Franny's too good and we
can't keep I was like this isn't too bad
at all I could listen to this all day
exactly there you go I love the positive
outlook I love it so much
um okay let's talk everything about the
episode I'm gonna start with the reward
challenge obviously very excited about
the tacos and margaritas like who
wouldn't be but after you you know you
dominate The Challenge and then there's
that extra layer of okay you guys have
loved ones notes yeah
how did your did like did you have a
strategy that changed or did you have
like a thought process going into it
when and then when Jeff threw that
curveball did everything change for you
or did you kind of know what you were
gonna do
so it changed for me in the sense that
now I'm looking at this group of people
and they're also crying and I have to
tell them that I'm not taking them you
know just made it so much harder but um
yeah I mean going in I knew that if I
won I wanted to bring Carolyn with you
know she's somebody that you know I got
along with really well but we hadn't
quite started working together
strategically yet and I really really
wanted to build that relationship
so Carolyn was a shoe-in and then as
soon as it became clear that it was
family letters I mean you know my heart
just went out to these moms like they
were missing their kids so much and I
was like I wanna I wanna be there and
see you get your letter and read your
letter
um but I feel good about my group I mean
you know Carolyn somebody I'm trying to
like transition a social relationship
into a strategic one Lauren somebody I
don't really have much going with but I
want to get a chance to talk to her in a
more like safe space and then I'm trying
to maintain what I already have with Ivy
so I felt like it was a good three for
me yeah absolutely I totally agree now
when you're at that reward Challenge and
you're enjoying all those moments are
you thinking about what the other
four people are doing Becca camp like is
that going through your mind or are you
trying to enjoy the moment a little bit
you know I was not thinking about that
as much as I should have been I think um
I think you know especially you know
when you're in these rewards and you're
having a taco
um sort of feels like you're on top of
the world and so yeah yeah I mean the
Margaritas were flowing like it was
great and we were talking about you know
strategically what we wanted to do back
at camp but I really discounted the fact
that you know those other four people
had like you know 12 hours to sit around
and talk about how much of a threat I
was I didn't even really realize when we
got back to Camp you know how big of an
obstacle that would be to overcome like
I assumed that my name had come up but I
mean it was hard to come back for from
that they did so much work while we were
at the reward I can only imagine how
much was actually done that we didn't
even see because every time I talked to
someone every week they always give me
some sort of tea about what happened we
didn't see and it's so fascinating to me
as a Survivor fan and I wish we could
get like an extended episode on like
YouTube with all of the extra stuff
because like there's so much that we
don't see oh yeah I mean if there was
like a like a big brother like like live
stream version like the 24-hour Survivor
stream I'd be on it all day long and I
love it too it's so good me too now I do
want to talk to you guys uh to you about
um Jamie saying that she didn't have her
Idol anymore yeah and which as a viewer
we all knew a it was fake and B yes Kane
did walk out with it but no one believed
her not one person what made you like
what made everyone be like no no no no
she has an idol like there's no way that
it went home with Kane like no one
believed her at all literally Not For a
Moment she walks away and we were
immediately like well that that was a
silly story yeah
I think for me I have a good reason to
believe that Jamie could have been lying
about that because when Jamie is swapped
to Soca you know we're asking her what
it's like at ratu how did that first
vote go down and she told us that it was
a majority vote on Maddie she didn't
tell us anything about the shots in the
dark nothing about the birdcage you know
them opening it all together and so when
I get to the merge and all of that
information comes out I'm thinking back
and I'm like whoa Jamie snowed me like
she's an Adept liar and so when she
comes to me the story is just so
ridiculous right like like what a
horrible turn of events that Kane
literally walks out with an idol in his
sock that I was like I'm not that silly
like you can't trick me it just sounded
so fake but yeah the layers to that are
just
ridiculous right she's telling the story
she's finally telling the truth nobody
believes her but the whole it was fake
the whole time yeah and then like even
at tribal like she brought it up again
and everyone was like
um what and everyone looks at Kane and
Kane is like
Dead face like he doesn't give anything
away which I thought was hilarious it
was so funny to watch Kane was so good
that man was like Stone Cold yeah you
can see Danny and I are like yeah but
for any sign anything and he just sat
there like
he's doing his jury job very well
exactly
um circling back though to the immunity
challenge like my heart was racing I was
like okay we all know Carson like puzzle
King like we know and he was at the end
I was like okay like he's running away
with it but then that piece didn't fit
you were coming in like it was so
intense obviously Gerson did end up
winning immunity and you know you talked
about how this is the first time in the
game really that you hadn't had a sense
of security going into tribal so after
losing that challenge and walking away
back to the beach like what was going
through your head and that in that
moment
um I think you can hear it in my voice
in my confessionals I was excited I was
like well you know like this is the game
like this is good stuff
um and I felt like I had a solid plan
you know I felt really really good about
this plan to vote out Danny that I was
you know working on with with you know
the people who were at the reward trying
to Loop in Jamie to that
um I thought that this was Gonna Be My
Big Moment Like finally I'm vulnerable
and like I'm best to them and yeah
unfortunately that's not what happened
but you know
I wasn't as scared as I should have been
I think I didn't even really realize how
big of a Target I had on my back because
looking at myself you know I'm like well
that was silly that I won those
challenges but it probably won't happen
again like from other people's
perspective it's like a big concern
um yeah that was a rough one to lose
yeah no absolutely and you know every
week has been chaos like before tribal
like there's plans there's so many plans
I swear there's like 10 plans every time
and every time as a viewer we go into
tribal I'm like I have no clue what's
gonna happen and even after like talking
to Jeff I still was like I don't know
what is gonna happen this episode but it
seemed like well clearly like a lot of
people weren't on the same page and you
know like
my question is like
I don't know it just like seemed like
everyone had no idea what was going on
so when you go into tribal like what was
your consensus like did you feel like
you had a group of people that you could
trust to be like okay we're getting out
Danny or did you feel okay I'm not sure
about these people kind of thing
yeah I mean let me be clear I did not
have a group of people that I trusted
right my biggest trust walked out when
Matt went home and then the next person
I was working with most closely after
that was Kane and so when Kane gets
voted out I'm like well shoot I need to
make some new friends so um for me the
most important conversation going into
tribal was that conversation you see
between me Carolyn uh Jamie and Lauren
where we're standing around we're like
why are we all so anxious why are there
so many plans let's just lock it down
right now and change it and do Heidi and
that was maybe 10 minutes before we left
for tribal so I felt good about that
plan in the sense that I was like this
is so like last minute it's so juicy
like it's the last thought in all of
these people's heads I felt confident
that that's what was going to happen so
I thought Heidi was going home
um but yeah I think given a little more
time maybe we could have not been so
anxious about it but we were just
running around like crazy that was a
wild day so other than you know you were
a challenge Beast was there anything
else like looking back now that you're
like oh maybe this was a reason that I
was such a big Target or was it mainly
the challenges for you yeah so I um I
like to talk I'm a big talker
um at you know at the challenges right
Jeff you know talks to you before the
challenge asks a couple questions I
almost always had something to say there
and I talked a lot at Tribal Council as
well and so I think that people were
also concerned that you know if I make
it to the end I can you know spin my
words to like get a win out of this
thing even though I'm kind of down and
out I don't really have any alliance
members so people seemed very concerned
about me from a lot of different angles
which is so funny to me I was like I was
like why I'm not I'm not so threatening
at all like what's happening but it's a
compliment you know it's all good yeah
exactly take it as a big compliment like
look at all the Survivor grades like
you're falling into that category girl
okay you are in that category
um now I do have to quickly ask you we
talked to Matt a few weeks ago and he
kind of gave us a little you know
relationship update so you know I just
wanted to hear from you like how is that
going did you guys Bond a lot while you
were on the jury together as well oh
yeah oh yeah so it's going great we are
still together long distance but making
it work because it's worth it
um oh that's so sweet yeah no I mean we
had such a special connection and like
and
getting into a Showman's is like it is
so out of character for me like I'm not
like a oh like relationships whatever
type of person and for it to happen on
Survivor I was like why here why now but
it's like Matt and I are just so you
know so on the same wavelength we
connected immediately and I was trying
to fight it fight it fight it I was like
game face but I couldn't you know and so
getting voted out like
at first I'm devastated this experience
is coming to a close but then I start
thinking I'm like oh I'm like I have
a solid week in Fiji with this boy
that's like really cute so we had a lot
of fun together at Ponderosa oh I love
that so much that's so sweet
um and speaking of the jury I quickly
want to ask you you know I've talked to
a few people about you know go now that
they're out of the game in terms of
being on the beach they're still in the
game they're on the jury their strategy
does have to change how does your
strategy change going into the jury and
you know watching and not you know you
don't see those big conversations on the
beach you only see who walks in with the
immunity necklace and you only see what
is in front of you like how does your
mindset change when you're on the jury
yeah it's totally different I mean being
on the jury is like trying to solve a
mystery because you have no clue what's
going on you only see this you know
slice of tribal council where everyone's
talking in like half truths and weird
metaphors and you're like what does it
even mean so for me
it becomes a game of trying to
separate my personal opinions about like
who I like and who I don't like who I
was working with and who I wasn't and
try to look at this game very
objectively and be like who has agency
who has information and who's going to
be able to demonstrate that to me at
final Tribal Council so I you know I put
my jury hat on very firmly and took this
very seriously but it's hard I mean we
go off of so little to make such a big
decision
um but hey I'm glad I was there there
you go and my last question for you you
know after this entire experience you
have a very positive outlook on
everything you know it was your dream to
be on the show but what would you say
was your biggest takeaway from your time
on Survivor like what did you learn
about yourself
yeah I
I feel like from this experience I
completely reshuffled my understanding
of myself what I bring to the table you
know what are my strengths and what are
my weaknesses like I completely
surprised myself in every aspect of this
game I legitimately thought I was going
to be the first person to go home I had
prepared my like I was gonna make a joke
about like remember who got voted out
twice I was like survivor's not kind to
Franny he's like I
learned from this that I need to stop
discounting myself because I think I'm
you know got so much more going for me
than I realize and I'm trying to like
take that into the rest of my life and
be proud of what I can do and you know
the connections that I can make with
people and and everything that I've
experienced
oh I love that so much what a great way
to round out this interview well it was
so lovely chatting with you you know
we're still going to see you on the jury
we're still going to see you on the
screen so you're not gone yet
um and yeah I'm excited to watch the
rest of the season thanks so much for
chatting with me today of course it was
great to talk to you